good morning Hank it's Monday Oh hold on
I feel like I might need to grow a
mustache oh god it's terrible somehow
it's worse because it's subtle but
anyway it's Pizza mmus the most magical
time of the year here in nerdfighteria
where for two weeks we make week daily
videos just like it's 2007 all over
again I don't like to brag but I think
my mustache that inspired Pizza miss was
the very first mustache not to know
whether it was ironic which is now like
a widespread phenomenon I can't explain
the whole backstory of pizza miss Hank
made a video about it once but every
year during Pizza miss dftba.com
Commission's lots of stuff on the theme
of my mustachioed face which is only
available during Pizza miss and today
I'm gonna unbox all that stuff I don't
know what any of it is oh oh there it is
oh boy alright let's get started with
this beautiful Pizza John mug if you
want to drink your coffee in a way
that's classy and sophisticated and just
slightly mustachioed then we have this
magnificently subtle Pizza John
sweatshirt it's a football scarf but for
Pizza John it's actually a surprisingly
comfortable scarf this is really is
shaping up to be the best pizza miss
ever at this point - Pizza John shirts
are like high art I mean look at this me
as a badass pizza delivery driver I mean
this is magnificent oh my gosh I have to
put it on now then we have this amazing
brick head meat pizza I've always wanted
to be a brick head I mean look at this
it's just a beautiful deconstructed
pizza with my face on it you're not even
gonna feel weird wearing this shirt
you're gonna feel awesome
and then lastly but certainly not least
it's nothing pizza with left John oh my
god nothing in 2019 has made me as happy
as none pizza with left beautiful and
stupid there's also a great sticker
collection in case you're looking to
adorn your phone or your laptop or any
other surface with my mustachioed face
did we finally make a bandana oh we did
look at this bandana I'm gonna do it I
feel like it's an obligation when I was
at summer camp I learned how to tie a
bandana now this was
thirty years ago but I bet I can still
do it
everything about this look is excellent
but what's best about it is this fella I
got to put on the shirt where I'm on the
Vespa these shirts are amazing all of
this is available only during pizza miss
at dftba.com go right now dftba.com yeah
false sense of urgency now that our
profits go to charity I've become a much
harder seller we have more stuff shut
the front door it's a pizza mess
underground map in which all the
stations are different kinds of pizza
and lastly we have two pins you can
choose between one that says pineapple
pizza forever and one that has a
pineapple with a line through it and
says nope I guess whichever of those
pins sell more will then be declared the
collective opinion of nerdfighteria INRI
pineapple on pizza it really is the best
beats of us yet thanks to everybody at
dftba and all the amazing designers who
participated in this weird project you
can go to dftba.com to get your pizza
and stuff now and wait I forgot two
important things fortunately I haven't
shaved my moustache first we've got this
Pizza John pennant so you can brag about
having gone to Pizza College and
secondly Sarah and I have been making
watercolor paintings together I know
it's it's so stinking cute and we're
making just a few of these watercolors
in the shape of pizza slices which we're
calling mystic pizza by John and Sarah
so yeah a few of these are also
available I think that's it happy pizza
miss Hank I will see you tomorrow